i love this about you you caption your
photos on instagram and it's hashtag
dreamchaser so was there a turning point
in your life that gave you drive and
positivity
yeah there really was it's um
it's
clear as day cause i remember so it was
and i try not to get emotional about
when i tell this story but it is very
emotional even to remember it all these
many years later but
there was a time when i was uh i was
closing on 30 and i
was still broke one year that i couldn't
afford to buy two two very young
children and i couldn't afford to buy
them christmas presents so i had to go
kind of tuck my tail between my legs and
go and ask my uh the guy was working for
at the time when i beca one of the club
promoters i worked for
if i could borrow money to buy my kids
christmas presents and i was so
embarrassed and
so humiliated to have to do that i just
i i just made that conscious effort that
i'll never do this again i'll never be
put in this position again
i needed to provide my for my children i
need to start building a life for myself
and not you know stop living week to
week and just you know in an easy job
that provided cash for me
on a nightly basis it's just i was
taking the easy way out and it was
leading absolutely nowhere so that was
when i started looking for things that
uh that i could do and i wasn't
qualified i wasn't educated i wasn't
skilled at anything
but i was very athletic and i had a
decent look and i thought maybe i could
find a future in professional wrestling
and that didn't pan out the way i
thought it would but i it did light a
fire fire under me too to pursue it
because my first trial was professional
wrestling they told me to leave get out
i'd never be a pro wrestler
and i i really just i was heartbroken
for about a week and then i was just i
was just
i was so i was like spiteful so i
started pursuing out of spite because
told me that i couldn't do it i i don't
know about you but i feel like i've been
driven by that i don't know if that's
healthy or not i'll ask my therapist
later today but i i
i literally like i've literally been
told you can't you can't you can't you
can't so many times you're not this
you're not this you're not this and i
think that honestly like
god the universe whatever you believe in
knows me well enough to know all right
and then watch me do it like it's like
all right i i see you and it kind of
pushes me to to i don't know better
myself and and and really pushes me to
really make something happen so maybe
you're that kind of guy as well
[Music]
you